If we think about global warming, which
we can all agree is a dire problem and a
problem that's getting worse. The instant
I start thinking about it as a type of
pollution—as pollution caused by
greenhouse gases—the problem becomes
clearer to me. And I say this, I don't say this to minimize the problem or
trivialize the problem at all. All I'm
trying to do is categorize the problem
properly. Because once you think about
greenhouse gases as pollution, then you
understand the toolkit for addressing
them. And in particular, the toolkit that
works really well for other kinds of
atmospheric pollution is: put a price on
the pollution. Make it a thing that
businesses have to spend on like they
spend for every other material out there, and then watch them try not to spend
money on it. Watch them flee from that
cost. This is what drove down our air
pollution levels so much. I imagine a lot
of us in this room have at least two
friends who are economists. If you have
at least two economist friends, you
realize that economists agree on nothing. And your two friends, or any number, will
just fight endlessly about any topic in economics. I say this to bring up the
fact that economists are not fighting
about the most powerful tool to address
global warming, to address greenhouse gas pollution. This is an open letter arguing
for a carbon tax. And in particular, a carbon tax where the government doesn't
keep the money; it just sends it right back out to the citizens of the country,
called a carbon dividend. This letter was
originally signed by a few dozen
economists. By now, the open letter has
been signed by more than 3,500 prominent
economists. This has never happened
before in the history of the discipline.
They would not sign a letter about the
sun rising in the east. But the the level
of unanimity here about the the most
powerful policy tool that we have to
combat global warming is just incredibly clear. And it's very frustrating that
we're not doing this, we're not even
taking it very seriously. Here's where we
left our whales in the early 1970s.
That's where the blue whales were. Here's
where they are now.
They're not all the way back, and they
might never get back to those previous
levels. But one phrase that I learned
from Stewart [Brand] the last time he and I were
together is one that I just carry around
with me all the time.
Stewart didn't invent this, but he said it
and I thought it was fantastic. It's:
'Nature bats last.' And if you carry that
idea around, you just come to the
conclusion that, look: we make mistakes
and we shouldn't make them, but if we can
get out of the way, if we can leave, if we
can leave the field, let the oceans
repopulate, don't hunt there anymore, stop
farming that land, and let it go back to
nature, nature can rejuvenate. It's
astonishingly resilient. Nature actually
bats last.